our draft for today the most interesting
2020 off-season storylines i've got the
trivia question for peter king if he
gets it right he gets the first pick
otherwise sims picks first and i think
we know
what the first pick will be here's the
question peter the chiefs went 50 years
between super bowl championships which
team is currently waiting the longest
for its next super bowl win
does that mean that they already need
they had to win one already yes
they had to win one
um
okay oh um
i will say
oakland
[Music]
the new york jets i don't know super
bowl three championships
to cap the 1968 season hey hey hey when
the lights are baby it's not easy you
choke
you hear the jeopardy music in your head
uh and uh and you choke all right
that's right don't worry peter we choke
on a daily basis you only have to do it
once a week but uh it is it's unreal
it's unreal um i know what you think i'm
gonna pick but i'm not gonna pick that
i'm not because to me
the thing i am most fascinated by this
off season is how much money patrick
mahomes is gonna make i this the
contract that that's where i'm i'm
interested to see i mean i really am to
me this is the most fascinating thing
and i know what you guys are gonna pick
and it's gonna be the brazen breeze
thing and i get it it's awesome but
i just i'm like
here's a quarterback that's so far
exceeded expectations in year two and
three of his career he's already the
best player in football he's the face of
the nfl he's overcome you know just you
know some amazing obstacles here and we
know that there's a whole cba and the tv
deal
and you know they're going to have to
break the bank in a way that we've never
seen before in the nfl i mean this is
going to be the first 40 million dollar
man maybe this is going to be the first
guy that actually gets to what mike
florio has always been saying a
percentage of the salary cap and forget
just about a hardline number so for me
that is the thing i'm most excited to
see because i don't think mahomes is
going to be very happy to go into the
season uh on this old contract and i
think kansas city knows that and they're
gonna have to find a way to pony up the
money and have a creative contract that
makes sense for mahomes for a long long
time
hey we have a lot of picks to make in
this segment but let me make one point i
have the story at profootballtalk.com
explaining it in more detail there one
of the biggest problems in doing a deal
this year is that mahomes is due to make
only 2.7 million so when you rip up the
two years left on his current contract
2.7 million this year roughly 24 million
next year as the fifth year option that
he'll be entitled to when you rip it up
and replace it with a five year well and
you don't reply you have a five year 200
million dollar extension you get into
this whole new money total value thing
bottom line if they sign him to a five
year 200 million dollar extension his
actual value at signing is 32 million
and that gap driven by a 2.7 million
dollar compensation package this year is
going to make it hard to do a deal this
year because you just can't make the
total value and the new money fit the
gap is going to be too large i think i
think there's a chance he doesn't get
his contract until next year peter
you're up
uh you know that's overthink you know
both of you guys are overthinking this
too much i think because i've never
heard one person call a talk show and
said and say hey how much money do you
think mahomes gonna sign for the fact is
the only thing that fans care about is
the guy is gonna play for that team
patrick mahomes is not playing anywhere
else whatever he makes how many zeros he
has in his bank account who cares nobody
cares all right having said that and
slapped you both in the face
i will just say
that without any question it's where
does tom brady land
um you know last week when there was a
tweet with tom brady in gillette stadium
in the shadows
uh the the free world went out of its
collective mind
and so
that by far
i don't care if patrick mahomes signs
for 90 million here you know tom brady
and his whereabouts this year with the
all-time greatest maybe player in the
history of the game that's the story of
the off-season
yeah
chris i don't know what you were
thinking
undoubtedly i
we spent a whole segment trying to
decipher that that escher drawing of tom
brady the top's walking in the bottom's
walking out what's going on i have more
people in miami last week ask me what
they think of mahomes contract than they
did where do you think tom brady's gonna
end up playing i'm just saying i had
more people talk to me about that
everybody thinks brady's going back to
new england so i understand yeah they're
to be in for a surprise i think we'll
say we'll say make a damn sense gloria
we'll see all right drew brees what's he
going to do is he going to retire is he
going to play we're going to have an
answer by the end of the month chris i
don't know about you but when we had him
in miami on friday on the show with us i
came away from that discussion believing
he's going to play one more you remember
when he slipped yes we were asking about
the 49ers and the chiefs he said we
played both of them
[Laughter]
i think he's going to play but until we
know the answer that's going to be one
of the big stories yeah i'm with you
there uh a hundred percent um
my next one is the pass interference
replay uh that that to me well what
about what's gonna happen there you know
what adjustments gonna be made is it
going to disappear all together i'm
really intrigued to where that goes i
mean it was not a success
successful uh experiment this year you
know i was not in favor of it all
together mike did they bring in the sky
judge like you talked about that thing i
don't know did they get rid of it all
together but either way it was a
freaking disaster this year and it was
annoying and they either need to get rid
of it or to totally reconstruct how they
do it
to make it more enjoyable and not to
throw fans into a crazy and not to throw
people like all three of us who we know
football pretty good and we don't know
what the hell past interference is on a
given week
uh my next one is the fate of the 2015
mvp
that's cam newton and not just where
he's going to play because that's the
first domino to fall
whether the panthers are going to have
him back at a fairly bargain rate
compared to what most quarterbacks make
okay are the panthers gonna have them
back for one more year just to see what
they have or
are the panthers gonna move on and then
secondarily
i think it's all about
what is cam newton who is cam newton for
the last two years we have not seen cam
newton at any degree of health for any
uh number of weeks in a row obviously he
missed almost all of last season and so
right now
i don't know who he is anymore and i
don't know if he's totally healthy all
of that is fascinating to me as well
obviously as where he ends up
peter i'm stunned i'm stunned i i had
pegged your second pick based upon
everything i've heard you say about the
guy who will be the quarterback in new
orleans after drew brees retires and
that's taysom hill and to me that is a
fascinating story how do the saints find
the cap space to keep him how do they
they play out this game of checkers and
chess and chicken over what level of
restricted free agency tender will they
invite the possibility of a team giving
them up a first round pick with an offer
they won't be able to match if they keep
drew brees they need to keep taysom hill
they need to feature stacem hill he was
the best player on the field for either
team in the wild card loss to the
vikings and i am fascinated to see where
this guy goes and what he does because
he's got superstar potential written all
over him
yeah uh i agreed there i mean yes he
does he has superstar i like both of
your guys picks i really do i mean they
were both good i i understand them
completely and the cam newton one is
fascinating and taysom hill
yeah he looks like he has the potential
to be a star and i don't know where he
goes man i'm a little torn about to do
here
with my third one but i think i'm gonna
go
you were praising you were praising our
picks just to buy time no because well
i'm torn in between whether i want to do
the quarterbacks in the draft because i
am interested in that the joe burrow the
tua angle right but i think ultimately
i'm going to go with dak prescott here
and that contract situation yeah i just
find that fascinating and it does look
like he's gonna get franchise but does
the deal get done after he gets
franchised at some point and also like
we've mentioned many times mike i mean
the cowboys are in the super bowl window
and prescott has a lot of power here
with a new coaching regime in town and
mike mccarthy and mike mccarthy is going
to want to get his error underway in you
know smooth fashion if you don't have a
long-term contract for your quarterback
going to be hard to get it off and do a
sm you know get the offseason off
smoothly without him there being the
leader of the team and the offense and
guys in the workouts and things like
that so i i don't know where this dak
prescott thing goes dallas has a lot of
juggling with a lot of different players
and contracts and things like that but
to me i find that pretty interesting
i can't believe that this is i'm with
the number eight number eight pick in
this draft right now and i'm not gonna
pick
where did the where does tampa go for a
quarterback with the you know do they
resign a guy who had 30 interceptions
last year or where a top 10 all-time
statistical quarterback goes what
happens to philip rivers but i'm going
with the possibility of three
quarterbacks in the top five in the
draft yeah does justin herbert sneak
into the top five right and
what does the quarterback uh what is
what is the richness of the quarterback
crop with tua and herbert what does that
do to washington's pick because i
believe that washington now
could totally rebuild its team if it's
willing to do two things pass on a
quarterback which it will do
and pass on chase young right they could
trade back twice and get up to three
additional first-round picks by trading
down could they do that
could they say hey listen we want to get
great volume over the next two drafts or
do we want a guy who's got a chance to
be lawrence taylor washington has a
franchise-defining
decision ahead of it and it all centers
around how much do you love herbert and
tua right
flips out of what they did in 2012 where
they were the ones who gave up all those
picks to move up to get rg3 they can
slide back and really get the pieces
that ron rivera needs to turn that team
around as quickly as he can in in a
division that that maybe washington with
a few good moves and a few lucky breaks
ends up being an unlikely contender in
2020 all right the last one for me i'm
going off the board completely i'm
trying to project what will happen
once the xfl starts playing games and
starts showcasing some different rules
how much will the xfl influence the nfl
we saw some influence in 2001 we saw
some ideas that the nfl cherry picked
from the xfl
what will happen this time around the
two-point conversion shootout to resolve
overtime how will that resonate with
fans what else that the xfl will be
doing will make its way into the nfl
either in 2020 or in 2021 i'm fascinated
by whether or not the xfl has a chance
to survive i still don't think spring
football is going to work because people
don't care about football in the spring
no matter how much they love football
they love it during football season but
there could be some very compelling
ideas remember last year with the aaf
they had that sky judge concept and now
that's become something we're pushing
for i know i am very aggressively for
the nfl what ideas from the xfl that we
see during the nfl offseason will make
their way into the national football
league all right that's our draft for
the most interesting story lines for the
2020 offseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports